*Jingle Golden Moustache*
De bon matin, ce jour là, Pharaon s'adresse à sa main d’œuvre.
'fin "main d'oeuvre" parce que, en fait,
c’était pas vraiment des esclaves, historiquement parlant.
Mais bon, donc, il faut dire main-d'oeuvre
mais bon on est pas dupe.
- Ooh ! Je suis Pharaooon. Je vous annonce
que la plus grande pyramide d'Egypte est terminée !
- Ouaaaais !!
- C'est pourquoi nous allons en construire une encore plus grande !
- Oooooh ....
- Des questions ?
- Quand vous dites "nous allons construire",
vous allez nous aider ?
*Son de fouet*
Ooh, humour d'esclave.
- D'autres questions ?
- Pourquoi est-ce-qu'on construit des pyramides ?
*Son de fouet*
Ah. Bien sûr.
- On pourra choisir nos équipes ?
*Son de fouet*
Ouais c'est vrai, c'est sympa les rencontres.
- D'autres questions ?
- Oui. Moi je me demandais...
*Son de fouet*
- Ok ! Mes ingénieurs ont estimé que,
pour réaliser cette construction,
il faudrait 45 ans de travail
et environ 160 000 blocs de granite
et pour vous faire porter le granite,
875 000 coups de fouet.
Ooh, mais bien sûr, 20 000 d'entres vous vont mourir,
écrasés par des grosses pierres,
ou dans d'horribles souffrances,
d'autres subissant les atroces morsures du soleil. Mais...
Mais quoi ?
Vous êtes des esclaves ou vous êtes des mauviettes ?
Vous êtes des es... des escl..
-...claves ?
- Voilà !
Alors, vous êtes contents ?
NOOOOOOOOOOON !
*Son de fouet*
Moyeeen euh !
YOUPIIII !!!
- Non, mes frères! Rebellons-nous !
- Vive le Pharaon !!!
- Mais non.. non.. mais non. REBEEELLONS-NOUS !
- Vive moyen le Pharaon.
Mais non mais plus. Beaucoup plus !
Rebellons-nous PLUUUS !
C'EST VRAI QUE SOCIOLOGIQUEMENT PARLANT,
C'EST UN REGIME BANCAL.
*Son de fouet*
Mais il y a des points positifs.
- Vive moyen le Pharaon.
*Son de fouet*
- Vive youpi le Pharaon !!!
- Hé ! On a rien dit de mal là.
Désolé. J'ai été pris par le rythme.
Et c'est ainsi que fut entrepris la construction
de la plus grande pyramide de l'histoire.
et que fut inventé l'ancêtre de la caisse claire de disco.
*Les esclaves dansent et chantent sous les coups de fouet*
*Générique de fin*